um we
suspected
let me let me back up
when trump got coveted
we knew what we were being lied to about
a lot of different things
earlier in the week and last week we
came to learn
that one of the things we were being
lied about with regard to trump's covid
was when he was sick and it is now
abundantly clear before it was 90 clear
now it's completely clear
trump had had a positive test
before
that infamous debate with joe biden at
which trump showed up late and his staff
said we don't know trust us
he was tested we're not going to test on
sight he was tested for covet we now
know trump had coveted during that
debate
we also suspected
that trump was way sicker than was being
admitted to by his doctors and his aides
his political aides
at that time and we now have more
information about that
uh thanks again
to mark meadows trump's form one of
trump's former chiefs of staff who has
now uh published a ton of information
about what was going on behind the
scenes we have learned number one that
donald trump's oxygen was not just a
little low but it was dangerously low
back in october of 2020 when he tested
positive for covid19
we also learned that
the diagnosis in general was far more
serious
that trump's medical team actually
pulled mark meadows aside and said
listen
his oxygen levels are really really low
for his age
86 or lower is very very dangerous
there is also the um revelation now that
donald trump was so weak that he could
not even carry his own briefcase and
that mark meadows was uh advised you've
got to convince trump to get to walter
reed hospital now
before things take a turn for the worse
because if you're trying to hide how
sick he is if the guy can't even walk to
the helicopter it's going to be
impossible impossible to continue hiding
it meadows went in to tell trump sir you
know we gotta move you it's time to go
to walter reed uh trump was supposedly
sitting up in bed in a t-shirt and
looked like he was not gonna be able to
go anywhere and meadows says you know we
always saw the guy in either golf
workouts or suit
golf outfits or suit and tie
um and trump looked very very different
here
he was a mess his hair was a mess on and
on
and mark meadows said to trump it's
better you walk out of here today under
your own power
than being brought out on a gurney or a
stretcher
and that was the time at which it was
determined by trump yeah i'd better go
uh and the idea was okay
um let's go out and carry your briefcase
but he's too weak even to carry the
briefcase we have now learned now are
any of these
details surprising
no we had every reason to suspect
that um trump was very very sick and
much sicker than was being admitted is
trump now admitting that this is what
went on no
no trump is denying these accounts and
saying
uh i didn't have covet during the debate
it's fake news uh all this different
stuff uh trump denies everything so it
seems pretty clear to me if you say well
what's the most likely thing here what's
the most reasonable and likely
explanation mark meadows is probably
telling the truth i don't know of any
reason particularly when you know that
if you
tell these stories being mark meadows
trump's going to lose his mind he's
going to slam you it's going to be
completely crazy
um and at the same time
it follows what we knew at the time dr
sean conley was being very very
squishy and evasive with
is did trump need oxygen he's not on
oxygen today
no but did he in the past since coming
here
um he has not been on oxygen today
okay when did he first test positive
i'm not going to look backwards we want
to look forward to the president
regaining his health it all fits with
everything that was going on trump
always wanting to minimize anything bad
and play up anything good
the very strange and narrow language
used by his doctors and on and on and on
so no shock no surprise
just imagine i mean i think the real
takeaway here is
imagine how
crazy things would have gotten
had trump refused to go to the hospital
initially and ultimately needed to be
brought on a stretcher
what what would that have done
um and if trump had ended up even sicker
and stayed in the hospital
closer to the elections i mean it all
the way it went ended up seeming not
that bad for trump at the end of the day
still ultimately did not get him
re-elected but it could have been much
much worse and we're learning that
through these revelations from mark
meadows